I am it was a giant like takeshi's
console takeshi's castle at 7:00 a.m.
every day challenge I used to wake up
early before school and I would like
watch every episode lost over like I
literally watched takeshi's castle all
throughout high school no no same in
those reruns oh yeah I loved it every
time yes the same episodes over and over
it's like it's like watching Top Gear
and down you know it's like it's it's
something you could always watch over
and over and it was just so [ __ ]
weird usually that I found out though
that like takeshi's Castle you guys had
yeah found a really interesting because
that's a shirt from the 80s yeah yeah
it's strange cuz I think America has
their own version as well bye bye
takeshi's Castle is this kind of
physical the most extreme game show was
it called ninja warrior something like
that like what's like the more Ninja
Warrior but imagine if it was like all
the contestants were just everyday
people and it was horribly unfair yeah
it was so unfair and it was so fun and
it was just brutal these these courses
they would just send people and they
were ninja warrior across the jackass
yeah [ __ ] dangerous I mean there's a
reason why they don't do that show any
no no no legit oh yeah yeah that show
had a huge following in the UK because
of rally and and I think America did as
well but each each localization had a
different style to it sir
the Japanese WOM she just showed the
show yeah a British one had like this
Craig Charles a Charles who's have quite
a famous person back in the 90s right
yeah because he did Robot Wars right
right yeah it was really big in America
they had like a kind of imagine like a
pseudo kind of football commentators
been like what do you think of that Jeff
yeah he's supposed to be like kind of
like jokey thinks I should watch clips
of it it's not as good but each country
had a Terran localization yeah whoo Kate
was huge because I remember those
petitions even when I was like 16 17
people wanting to bring it back but I
mean how can you bring it back by just
dumping over the old but a Thailand
actually had I think a version like a
few years ago as well okay they made
their own version because I remember
watching and thinking like not the same
thing quite scratch but that was a huge
factor in why also I love Japanese
culture because you watched
show in light it's it's crazy it's
amazing and it's also a blatantly
extremely Japanese yeah you're seeing
like katakana kanji everywhere like it's
obviously just like it's it's purely
just like ADHD like editing you know I
know it's pure like yeah that's my first
introduction to like using Japanese your
chaos I don't know but what it is about
Japanese variety shows it's just about
having as much information on screen to
like distract your eyes as possible I
start making YouTube videos I have come
to like feel sorry for every Japanese
editor oh the entire amount of text they
have to put on the screen changing
colors and [ __ ] popping up everywhere
because everybody's dialogue has
sometimes it's like we can hear them
fine do you know what I hate when I
whenever I see like an anime trailer and
it's from like Japanese TV so they
always got like this guy reacting to a
or something yeah game shows they'll
have like yeah and really like like
normal thing of us have a guy in the
corner like yeah
it's like a really interesting
behind-the-scenes clip of this anime or
show well like one of like I remember
seeing like the giorno Kent clip of the
guy doing muda yeah right and there's
just a gargantia in the corner I was
like I don't give a [ __ ] about my god
take you scream I have to say that like
with takeshi's castle yeah I [ __ ]
loved growing up
oh my job uh sure what was your guys
like favorite like segment of that show
because for me like to this day if I
have a bad day I'll always watch clips
of the lotion staircase see I think they
have different names for them yeah yeah
challenges title screens yeah I could
tell that they call up try to mimic I
mean did you guys watch like the lotion
States like they it's like a giant
staycation it's just covered in lotion
and oh yeah yeah I remember that one I
like I like the the one where they would
the honeycomb maze like the hexagon maze
although I was really this maze and like
and you got a up top down view which is
so good and you would see them go
through this maze and they're basically
these [ __ ] dudes which grab them in
the face them around there's also like
the rolling things that they know the
one the one I think that's my mind is
the one where they're like rock skipping
like
you you [ __ ] you [ __ ] go full pelt
over these like rocks over a river and
some of the rocks would just would just
sink yeah I'll just imagine if like
you're running full pelt and then one of
the rocks sinks and you just faceplant
into a real rock oh my god
I'll live too painful if you haven't
watched it you're in for a treat it's
just it's so good it's such good fun I
don't think a show like that good could
happen
[Music]